eight projects are on the way but we're
going to focus on one right now that
will air on CBS because it goes further
than any other show to find answers we
want to get the truth out so that Jon
Benet could rest in peace let me address
it very directly I did not kill my
daughter Jon Benet God knows who you are
and we won't find you who killed Jon
Benet a new docu-series examines the
cold case in several remarkable ways
first the team built a full-scale
replica of the Ramsay house
we took a seventy thousand square foot
warehouse in Boulder Colorado we got the
original plans to the house crime scene
photos videography of the house and we
built it from scratch because we built
the place we could test theories also of
interest the alleged entry point into
the house a small window barely visible
from the outside see it's restricted it
won't open all the way which gives you a
very little bit of room to actually get
in through here this is the location
where the letter was found the ransom
letter and it's at the bottom of the
stairs that lead right up to the outside
of JonBenet's room the thing about this
letter is that is six to ten times as
long as the average ransom note that
ransom note is another focus of the
investigation the team actually timed
out how long it would take just to
physically write the letter
twenty-one minutes just mechanically it
took 21 and a half minutes just to write
this thing if it were original text it
would have taken so much longer I think
we can all agree this letter is clearly
staged all that analysis is another key
part of the special original
investigators teamed up with new experts
independently those investigators all
reach the same conclusion they're pretty
certain they know what happened that
night
and I think when viewers hear the
evidence laid out from beginning to end
they will agree there's only really one
way it could have gone down this is so
fascinating the case of JonBenet Ramsey
will air two hours a night for three
nights starting on the 18th I'm
wondering if the theory that I always
thought happened is what the
investigators will say a thing happened
as well I'll be watching